let's begin this hour with the Emmy
nominated Ted lasso star taheed jamo the
actor just returned as the Beloved
character Sam obisanya in season three
of the Apple TV plus series and he stars
in the upcoming Prime video series the
power out next week Anthony Mason met up
with the 25 year old in London and GMO
talks about bringing a piece of himself
his Nigerian Heritage to his two biggest
roles yet
is this where you used to play yeah man
this is we used to do football tryouts
here johive jamo took us back to his
middle school field at the Norwood
School in the Brixton neighborhood of
London I'm going to flip now because I'm
on camera it's here he learned the moves
that he shows off playing soccer star
Sam obisanya on Ted lasso Take a Bow Sam
obisanya the first trick of his career
you came to the part with some real
experience though yeah yeah like I grew
up playing football
um like my entire time through school
football was the main sport around here
Jamal never played professionally but he
did win a local school tournament I
remember I went crazy and I used to wear
my medal to school every single day in
the next two weeks from Norwood jamo
went on to drama school and a year after
graduating in 2019 landed his first film
role what do you want to be a small part
in West Anderson's the French dispatch
and you rubbishop and then in pretty
quick succession in that same summer I
got Ted lasso and the power crazy yeah
it's been a bit of a whirlwind today we
have a very very very special guest okay
in the new Prime video series The Power
Jammu plays tunde a Nigerian journalist
who discovers that a group of young
women has developed a mysterious power
to generate electricity through their
hands in the first episode you literally
get a shock yeah yeah
is a really mind-boggling thing like it
poses really dope questions about power
and and you know who has it who doesn't
yeah posed really interesting questions
about the power dynamics between men and
women has it changed much no it's
exactly the same jamo discovered his
love of acting here at Norwood it felt
bigger when I was here but I guess I was
probably just little you know this was
your stage this was my stage I did all
of all of my rehearsals here I did all
of my performances here like I lived in
this room this was like the birthplace
of like me wanting to be a performer he
wanted to be an actor this was my safe
haven oh God his courage to pursue it
professionally was inspired by his
instructors this is one of my teachers
hello Martin blakelock
um this is the man I used to force I
used to like sit you down over here and
just like yell Shakespeare at you I
remember you did up there yeah you did
[Laughter]
also introduced us to Marcus Condren
Deputy head of Performing Arts at the
school he says you changed his life
that's very nice yeah thank you do you
remember that time that you pulled me
into your office and and like you sat me
down and you were like I think you can
you can like um
I think you can be an actor yeah like
rather that meant a lot to me hello
oh my God I always cry when I'm on the
stage genuinely
um I had a really like profound impact
on me and and like I owe so much of what
I'm doing now to you and and I'm like
just I can't thank you enough because
you didn't have to like you went above
and beyond for me and um yeah I
appreciate you I want to stop crying now
but what did you see in him
it's easy and it's hard to say at the
same time I think you see the talent and
then it's we always say to them then the
hard work comes and he had plenty of
that as well so you know not not always
the best behave at all points throughout
his school Journey
but he's a school hero now for his
starring role in Ted Lassen oh my God so
oh sorry Miss Alton hi call me Rebecca
Rebecca Rebecca sorry in the last season
Sam's story took an unexpected turn when
he began dating an older woman no no no
no you are way too young I mean what
like 24 I'm 21. oh my God I'm a
pedophile did you know the romance was
coming in season two no you didn't no
nobody told me about that
we were reading the screen I was like I
see the last time I spent this long in
bed it was because I strained a
hamstring
that older woman was team owner Rebecca
Welton played by the emmy-winning Hannah
wattingham
something I should warn you of
I don't even think it's more wonderful
I know fans used to message me and be
like is there anything romantic or is it
just platonic and I was honest but like
I think what they hit on was that there
is a connection between those two
characters and yeah I thought it was
really really special and you two were
friends off screen as well yeah yeah
she's she's dope she's a rockstar that
woman um and I think that's why I also
felt really comfortable about it
when Sam faces a critical decision in
season two he looks in his locker at a
photograph of his parents those actually
are your parents my real life parents
yeah yeah Simon tahib or like one in
that moment gmo's father and mother are
Nigerian immigrants my whole life has
kind of been about
like where I fit in I kind of felt like
I fell in between being a British kid
and being a Nigerian kid and never
really felt like a part of either Club
born in Britain jamo spent his early
childhood in Nigeria returning to London
around age seven so your first memories
are in Nigeria yeah my first accent was
a Nigerian accent and so yeah again like
it's really dope because I get to play
two Nigerian characters in Salmon tinde
um in what is actually my like first
voice you know so I always find it
really weird how now my career has taken
me back to the thing that I kind of like
got rid of to to fit in you know yeah
must have made your parents proud though
yeah yeah I think so my dad's the like
one of the most stoic people ever so
like I could do anything I could win 14
Oscars tomorrow and he'd just be like
good
he's good yeah my mom always had an idea
that I was going to be the UK's first
black prime minister
um maybe I'll play him one day
that's that's not gonna happen
the next episode of Ted lasso drops
tomorrow on Apple TV plus and the power
premieres on Prime video March 31st I
saw the first episode it looks really
promising it's an exciting show you know
the other thing that's really
interesting about about tahib is he was
one of the few black kids from Brixton
to get into drama school that was a huge
achievement in itself and the school
celebrated him for that but as you see
he's made the most of it it's that high
wattage Smiley is first of all that just
lights up the screen remember when he
seems like such a nice guy and is your
piece is often
it just touches on all the hard points I
love when he was with his coach oh yeah
I love the storyline with him and
Rebecca of course with the older woman
and the younger man I love that
storyline why do you love that storyline
I just do
because you I noticed you were very
focused on
but but to give us some insight into him
who he came from and what his background
is so nice it's so interesting circling
back to to being Nigerian because that
was really tough for him being born in
Britain he thought of himself as British
but but you know he couldn't be seen as
either one in effect see it's nice as he
seems I know absolutely yeah absolutely
and you know that moment with his coach
yes he literally took us to him he
wanted he wanted to to introduce us to
his coaches okay I've already seen the
first episode of Ted last I can't wait
for the new one yeah
I really like it Anthony thank you very
much